la plage des pêcheurs de copacabana
était un lieu favori de promenade il s'y
passe toujours quelque chose
le retour de la pêche est un spectacle
on y parle politique aussi à quelques
jours de l'élection le candidat
d'extrême droite gerb also know reste
largement en tête
cantona bon journal nous allons voter
pour bolton arrow la gauche plus jamais
nous voulons du changement
cabaye a beau sonar n'y a pas d'option
la gauche ne marche pas c'est selon les
sondages plus de 90% de ceux qui disent
vouloir voter pour bolton arrow ne
changeront pas d'avis début septembre
jaillir bolzano a reçu un coup de
poignard qui l'a gravement blessé il dit
qu'il est encore convalescent qui doit
limiter ses activités et qu'il ne peut
surtout pas participer à des débats
télévisés que réclame son adversaire
jacques bolson arrow achève
tranquillement sa campagne ici derrière
l'enceinte privé de sa résidence
dans loin de la mer en banlieue de rio
il sort très peu et surtout il reçoit
beaucoup de personnalités importantes en
fait il en fait le moins possible c'est
un bon moyen d'éviter de commettre des
erreurs
cette délégation de députés va lui
rendre visite c'est le lobby des armes à
feu l'un des 3 b de ses partisans b
comme bal des autres besson la bible les
églises évangéliques et chrétiens
traditionalistes et le boeuf c'est à
dire les grands agriculteurs sa campagne
elle se fait tout seul dans les réseaux
sociaux facebook mais surtout whatsapp
qui est la messagerie de tous les
brésiliens
il y circulent des messages audio
mensonges et financé illégalement par de
grandes entreprises partisane de bol
sonar ou les déclarations haineuses
raciste misogyne homophobe de cet ancien
militaire obscur député depuis 30 ans
ont choqué mais elles n'ont pas freiné
son avance son image reste quand même
celle d'un personnage odieux ne laissons
pas qu'une fois le contrôle au monde
il n'est pas comme ça dans la vie il est
sympathique normal dit paulo storani qui
le connaît bien
c'est un provocateur
c'est sa stratégie 17 anciens du
bataillon des forces spéciales le fameux
pop et qui ne compte pas parmi ses
partisans ses déclarations malheureuses
correspondent aux personnages dit il il
a fait une campagne intelligente c'est
le seul qui s'est confronté à
l'establishment brésilien il a fait sa
carrière comme ça en train de parler des
choses pour l'éthique mans considéré
politiquement incorrect et s'est
positionné comme un justicier contre les
politiquement correct ok ça c'était une
stratégie qu'apportait des votes surtout
ball sono a su surfer sur le rejet du
parti des travailleurs de l'ex président
lula et de son successeur le candidat
fernando haddad par dessus tout le rejet
de la corruption des partis politiques
traditionnels les sondages disent même
que les femmes vont voté majoritairement
pour ce candidat ouvertement misogyne
bretagne personnages n'ont pas besoin de
cette femme votre à molson araud mais
elle est résignée triste pour la gauche
dont elle ne veut plus
le brésil est sur la corde raide tout va
mal que va-t-il choisir pour le sortir
du pétrin
de quel côté va-t-il tomber la vieille
gauche usé plus probablement celui de l'
aventure de l'extrême droite populiste
jean michel leprince sera du canada rio
de janeiro